all right so Jonah he gets a call from
God and God tells them that there's a
city Unova that's falling into moral
disarray now what does that mean well
it's the universal story it's like all
cultures are always falling into
disarray it's their nature just entropy
does that right things change the world
changes the environment changes and the
culture doesn't keep up very well and
then of course it has corrupt elements
and so it's an enduring eternal story
the individual is always placed in
relationship to a culture that's
somewhat corrupt and then the question
is well what you do about it and if the
answer is nothing well then it'll just
get more corrupt and if the answer is be
corrupt - then it will just get more
corrupt so the answer has to be to
oppose the corruption because that's the
only way it's going to stop now god
threatens to destroy this city because
of its corruption and I don't think you
need to presume anything particularly
metaphysical about that to understand it
it's very straight forward that the more
corrupt the culture is and the less
Trust is possible between individuals
the less productive the culture is going
to be because why do anything if some
corrupt person is just don't come and
take it you know it might even be me
that the culture is so corrupt that if
you are good for something and you
produce resources you're actually more
likely to get killed because you have
something of value so it like this just
you're just not going anywhere with that
and why would you work if you didn't
have any sense that you know you could
store up the value of your work for some
reasonable time in the future so if the
society is corrupted there's no trust
it's degenerating and you know it might
live for a while but isn't gonna last
very long and so that's the idea corrupt
societies collapse
that leaves open what corruption means
anyways
Jonah thinks no oh it's no bloody way
I'm not going to that city they can go
to hell as far as I'm concerned and
that's really what he thinks and why in
the world should I do anything about it
anyways and these are good objections
it's like why would you do that and
you'll face this believe me in your life
you will face this in fact you already
do always constantly continually in slow
ways perhaps when you're interacting
with people who aren't treating you
properly when you're acting and those
might be your parents they might be your
friends they might be people at your
workplace they might be professors
they're playing a crooked game and you
don't like it and you know it's crooked
and so then the question is well what
should you do about it well if you know
your crimp know it's crooked it's not so
good to play along with it I mean we'll
say that you know it's crooked by your
own standards of values it D degrades
you to play along with it
you're going to stand up and oppose it
well no probably not you're probably
going to do what Jonah did jump on a
ship and get the hell out of there and
you know that's a logical thing to do
but it doesn't solve the problem and I
think this has something to do with
human ethical responsibility because
there are other old stories and I'll
tell you one likely where the son of the
King the Lion King the son of the king
he goes off and he's some pathetic
adolescent and then he shamed by the
reappearance of his old girlfriend into
turning into something vaguely useful
and he opens his eyes and he goes back
and he fights scar and know it's a scene
of Hell right because it's fire
everywhere and he fights star finds out
scar killed his father casts him into
the pit roughly speaking and then the
rain comes and then you know the movie
returns to its beginning fundamentally
paradise paradise lost'
Paradise Regained that's the movie
and that's the story of human beings you
know you're in a place that's working
out pretty well something happens to
knock you off your perch you're down in
the chaos for a good amount of time and
maybe you never get out
but maybe you learn something down there
maybe a strength in your character then
you pop up to a new place and maybe it's
better that rain better you now I'm not
being overly optimistic about this I
know perfectly well that people
encounter impediments during their life
that they find almost impossible to
recover from but it's the best shot you
have so anyways Jonah runs away but God
isn't very happy about that because it's
actually Jonah's destiny it's necessary
for Jonah to repair the city so God
sends a storm and you know the waves are
high and and and I think what that means
is because the water is often a symbol
for the unconscious and that's because
things lurk down there in the water and
that you could pull up that that are
useful monstrous things but you can pull
up they're useful you can fish for them
you can go fishing in your own being for
answers which is what you do when you
try to think all right you ask yourself
a question and you wait maybe an answer
appears it's like where'd that come from
you didn't know what the answer was
before it appeared but it just popped
into being out of nowhere who knows so
you fish so anyways the waves come and
the boats going to be knocked over it
and that's what happens I think when you
know when you know you should do
something I mean everyone has the
Disick's perience I believe perhaps you
would be willing to put up your hands if
this experience is foreign to you okay
this party are telling you you should do
something and it's hard to do it
effortful and maybe you're afraid of it
and so you don't do it you just
procrastinate right and so how do you
feel about that
good I mean so what you feel that you're
betraying yourself your anxiety actually
gets worse not better even though you
know you can
moment-to-moment but that doesn't help
because every time you put it off the
anxiety just grows a little bit you're
not proud of yourself you have a sense
that you're making things more chaotic
than they should be you know and if you
do that long enough and I'm sure many of
you have had that experience if you do
that long enough it's that becomes
habitual things will get so stormy
around you that you'll fall right into
the into the chaos into the watery chaos
and maybe you'll drown so it's not a
very good idea to run from your destiny
let's say whatever that might be and you
need a destiny you need a place to aim
at because that's what gives your life
meaning and you need meaning in your
life because life is hard so you know
you need something to buttress yourself
against that so anyways they wage own up
and Jonah says that's probably my fault
because like I'm running away from
something I'm supposed to do and you
know God is very happy about that so
what'd he just throw me over to
overboard and the crew is very happy
about that but the waves are really
starting to come up and Jonah's pretty
insistent that he's the cause of the
problem and so they draw they draw a lot
and and Jonah is chosen and so they
decided to toss him into the ocean and
immediately everything's calm so he's a
center of chaos because he's not doing
what he's supposed to do fine well then
a whale comes up and follows him then
he's in the whale for three days now
that's a weird thing the whale that's
the whale that Gepetto's in that's a
dragon it's a thing that you have to go
out there and conquer to get something
of value now when you've made an error
when you've fallen off the pathway when
you deviated from what you know you
should do it produces a state of
internal chaos and worry and concern
you're thrust into the unknown you're
thrust into unknown territory and chaos
don't know what to do and that's often
symbolized by the encounter with a with
a monster like a dragon or something
that lives under the water that's and I
think the reason for that is as far as
I've been able to tell is that human
beings because we've been prey animals
for forever in our battle with
carnivorous lizards for example in
alligators and even dinosaurs because
there were dinosaurs around at the time
of our most distant ancestors there was
even a cat at one point that was that
was adapted with teeth to pierce human
skulls so it had a head that was exactly
shaped to grab you here and put a tooth
through the back of your skull so like
we've come through some rough times man
and we have a system in our mind that's
a threat predator detection system
that's the thing that makes little kids
think about monsters in the dark right
because well there is monsters in the
dark parents always say well there's no
monsters in the dark it's like that's
not true the dark is full of monsters
there might not be any in your room
right at that moment but that doesn't
mean there aren't monsters in the dark
crimes take place like criminals don't
get up at 6:00 in the morning and like
you know have breakfast and go rob a
bank they do it they do that sort of
thing at night people do the things that
are fit for the night in the night and
lots of predators are nocturnal and you
can't see very well in the dark and kids
aren't stupid
you know they've evolved to stay pretty
damn close to the fire because the kids
that wandered away from the fire got
picked off by hyenas and lions and you
know crocodiles and whatever else the
hell was out there to eat the unwary so
the circuit that we use to defend
ourselves against predators as we've
evolved cortically that circuit has have
come to represent what we don't know in
general if the Predators of course
inhabits where we don't know and so
evolution is a conservative force and we
use the circuits that we've evolved to
represent new things and so the unknown
the chaos is often represented by a
monster that swallows you up and pull
you down and you know when you're
feeling terrible you don't say well I'm
feeling up you say I'm feeling down well
why is that well down is worse I guess
you're flat on the ground when you're
down or you're in a hole or something
like that you're hiding in a hole
you know it's down and you're threatened
by something you know maybe you're
threatened by your own inadequacy that
might be part of it maybe that's partly
what you imagine as a monstrous force
because you know your proclivity towards
procrastination and your weakness of
character it's part and parcel of why
you happen to be in the underworld and
that's the underworld the mythological
underworld that's where you go when
things fall apart and if you understand
that if you know that that's what that
means then you have one of the keys that
opens up ancient stories to you and you
understand things you could your life
can be organized
going very well and then something comes
up and boof
everything changes some axiom that you
were living by and it might be the
existence of a partner might be a job it
might be your health any of those things
gone and you go somewhere when that
happens you go somewhere it's a state of
being you're still in the same world but
it's not the same at all anymore
everything about it is different it's
all negative and dark and you don't know
what to do you're confused and so what
do you do down there in the underworld
when things are falling apart especially
if oh if it's worst possible case
scenario and you realize that you
actually had something to
do with your demise that's really
annoying you know when something bad
happens to you and then you know you
grind yourself into bits trying to
figure out what the hell happened and
then you realize that well you were
playing to cause a role now sometimes
you're so depressed you assume you're
playing a causal role and you work it's
not easy to figure out by any stretch of
the imagination and it isn't that
everyone who does something terrible is
it fall for it but sometimes you find
that you are off the path somehow and
maybe even that you knew it and didn't
attend to it and that's why all of this
hits the fan and so then down there in
that chaos you decide that you're going
to do what you're supposed to do instead
and then maybe you get to rise up again
renewed if you're lucky and then you can
go fix the city and that's what this
story's about and that's why I picked
the image to represent the course
because really what happens you see with
the psychoanalyst the road due to health
if you're not doing well which means
that as you act in the world you're not
getting what you want there's something
wrong with your the match between your
presuppositions and your actions
habitual and the way the world is
responding to you and so it's not
turning out for you and the question is
well what can you do about that
and one answer might be to examine
yourself for presuppositions and action
patterns that are not serving you well
and to find out what they are and what
to do about them and maybe some of that
is maybe you're not moving forward
because of fear and maybe that fear is
grounded in terrible experiences that
you had in the past that you've never
been able to understand and maybe one of
the ways of gluing yourself back
together and expanding your personality
so that you could in fact live properly
in the world is to go back to those
terrible events and untie them and
straighten them out and understand them
and drop them and that's what
psychotherapy is about in large part
psychoanalytic behavioral doesn't matter
what are you afraid of what
you avoiding what are you failing to
develop maybe from fear maybe from
avoidance god only knows maybe from
disgust how can you get over it how can
you reclaim those parts of your self